people of the internet welcome to the
real rejects i'm gray
i am aaron we're gonna watch umbrella
academy season two
episode eight the seven stages we
episode eight get through seven okay
guys hit the subscribe and click the
notification bell
button to get notified when our next
umbrella academy reaction is up
or if something else pops up in your
feed that's like oh wow
youtube only allows for 10 minutes worth
of footage of the show to be included if
we're lucky so this is called reaction
highlights full length
reaction watchalogs uncut over at our
patreon pitch go check it out
over there we got so many shows that we
cover look at that
wow that's a thumbnail beautiful so many
of these shows have reaction highlights
and watch alongs included at the same
tier
you won't regret it and uh we've got a q
a podcast
i just want to list all those shows
right
there's a lot
[Music]
oh vania she looks familiar she looks
like the same level of white that
vania is
[Music]
i'm curious as to how you know your
first and last name but you don't
remember anything else
i just realized
[Music]
remember the first episode of the series
when this the girl swimming in the water
yeah it's coming back
seriously is a communist threat to this
country
[Music]
you're not going anywhere until i find
out who you really are
oh get out of there just leave woman
who's choking him oh
what are you doing here whoa
sure just turned them old
clever ah i see it that's cool
forever it's a lot of people i know
technically his brother killed him and
they were not here to sell
vacuums
yeah i've been thinking about it from
that perspective just anyone who comes
here
just rumor them to go kill themselves
yes you gotta go to the future with them
allison
they're so worried about you [ __ ] you in
your good times gonna be one of those
nights
[Laughter]
oh damn he's like the leader too cut
your own hand off
you're gonna need that hand dude you
don't need to don't do that because if
you chop that one up i can chop the
other one off
um
what oh he's realizing it's fake
oh ah i love how that little detail came
back
your vagina needs glasses your vagina
needs
five and glasses we have quite a
colorful history
you could say that again
are you gonna kill jf kai
that's how grace sounds down perfectly
my name grace
[Laughter]
what's your plotting horograms are you
involved in something
nefarious quite often you're gonna kill
her
what if they don't kill jfk
hmm i forgot to save him oh
no reggie no
no john he feels he has
actual emotions emotions
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
oh god would that only affect the old
five or that affect him too him too
okay like bane from the harley quinn
yeah i totally see it
what are we doing the fbi
thinks she started by being a gay
[Laughter]
what's the point of the kj
okay
[Laughter]
why would he
[Laughter]
wow what a shot that's a great
representation of the strength of
whatever's in that bottle oh
great shot is she going to get her
memory back
she's going to trip balls some lsd yeah
she's gotta get her memory back right
oh no oh eyeballs
that's not ew
oh jesus did they do this do they use
lsd to torture people
she's remembering oh snap
whoa what the hell
oh
man
oh fascinating
this is not gonna go well
[Laughter]
shouldn't luther just go
oh how cool number one
it's like a spielberg movie
got like a hamlet entertainment viber
so cool he's being his older younger
self
but how do they decide what is the
correct timeline
oh [ __ ] you don't want diego doing this
don't worry diego's gonna try to course
correct
everything and they have all that power
her job was to maintain the tie line
because you know he solely wanted to
kill jail
does this make sense
that the actor did not know what he was
being told to react to
i'm just gonna go to the infinite
why would you trust this guys
oh you're gonna have it ain't gonna have
it something doesn't feel right about us
i'm paranoid bro
he's so great my god everyone is so
brilliant this season
i'm just tripped out he's working the
time bureau and he's at the time bro
wouldn't they know he's going to change
because this is
i know dude why don't you just wait it
out
i'm just gonna start plugging [ __ ] in
get yourself a briefcase man breeze k
briefcase
diego has barely used any knives
you're a legend really
mr hunters you can't be in here
is that any way to talk to a legend i'd
authorize
herb you're my new favorite character
[Music]
causes
wow
how we get into the whoa
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] she breathes about
to
say again
wow
oh my god that is a
brilliant reveal holy [ __ ] again
wow that was a clip from season one that
was so good
yeah it was a clip from season
[Laughter]
thanks oh i'm so worried for him
what the hell the resistance forget
about the little jerk off split it's
a complicated
[Laughter]
i mean you oh [ __ ] luther besides
it's too late for him
paradox psychosis i'm not killing
anybody
look at me
oh my god this is great
i've never felt better in my life
luther you're a freaking idiot
[Laughter]
man i can't get over that vonye reveal
that was crazy
that was brilliant that's that's like a
brilliant twist man
wow they did it again yeah
that doesn't feel repetitive either
that's
chooses brilliant to remember ah so
she's just like so traumatized from it
all
right i think that's what it is
a mom oh god
brains
eat your brain vania oh but if diego can
save her and get her out of there
brains brains
don't eat your brain girl
remember
don't do this oh they're tethered
it's like stranger things yeah totally
he's totally very stranger things
it's awesome
[Music]
that's so nice
that's great i love that again
oh i love these two they're very sweet
how did raymond just become so
understanding
yeah i thought that was gonna be a whole
other plot thing to have to deal with
but you guys can stop vanya and turn
this around
that's not bad oh no so she was hiding
she was choosing to run away from it she
blocked it out
that's a big bite girl
oh man oh man
oh man oh [ __ ]
what is happening with him i'm so
confused
girl dude you're gonna blow up the
freaking building man
oh my god stop her go
do something oh my god this can't happen
again
oh [ __ ] senbanen yes yes
how'd that blood get there oh no
oh my god hell yeah jesus they deserve
it
[Music]
what does it mean
oh man i thought there was like at least
15
20 more minutes left oh wow that was so
good
that was wildly intense that last like
10-15 minutes minutes
that's crazy oh my god let's talk about
it that was that i was on a hedge man
this show blows my
[ __ ] mind
[Laughter]
i know we say it a lot but man this
show's so good
what a great reveal just the concept of
it when you know like
in that first episode when they when
five first shows up it's like soviets
what
yeah yeah they went to war with them
what the hell and then the reasoning for
that like it's woven together in such an
a beautiful way and like
there's such misdirection in the way
that the the story is playing out
because you think it's like we still
know how hardware plays a role into this
but we think that he's like the catalyst
for the thing that causes the soviet war
then in the end it's always
bonya that causes the the apocalypse and
it's such a way more complex way
of how it kind of uh is presented
because she's the bomb which causes
paranoia which causes
war rather than the moon destroying the
earth that was just so
it was i'm so impressed with this show a
lot of the times of my
what's the point of this storyline
sometimes i'm wondering okay
how does this lead to what exactly right
because you know there's always a bigger
picture in mind and the way we've gotten
here
is so brilliant it's just absolutely
brilliant the intensity i love that
sequence of
vania getting into her memory and
choosing
not to remember like she's afraid to and
you got this literal metaphor of like
swallowing her own brain with the
memories in there
yeah and then them in a rush to get to
her before
she becomes the bomb but the russell t's
in this other
element with harlan who's connected to
her and has the powers to
crazy because the essence doesn't put
the thing
in here you know he has the powers and
like and they have no awareness about no
one knows about that
like the audience no one else
left field the fact that she's affected
the timeline in this way by giving this
kid these powers
yeah and like when five traveled to is
like oh wow that's so crazy they prevent
kennedy's death but something much
worse happened yeah it's like it's a lot
more complex than you originally
was kind of presented to you you kind of
had layers to the the level of the
apocalypse
i'm just like man just the way
information was even presented like what
you said about vania about how
she was choosing to the whole time the
show makes you think that it was the
the car yeah the ammunition of the the
car hitting her but
it was by her own will that she was
choosing not to remember what happened
to her
i mean you kind of have like the
psychological denial element even being
infused tying it in with
five's experience with whatever that
paradox thing is that they have when
five meets five
ten get it
five meets five at the restaurant and
the paradox that occurs in like the
first stage is denial
and i love the i mean man whoever plays
luther is so hilarious he's
so good i'll say whoever plays older
five or younger brother really
technically is brilliant like you can
totally see like this is that same dude
but
way older like their mannerisms are kind
of the same they kind of have that same
sort of
snarkiness i guess to them is it the
same actor from season one
it is yeah the one that you're seeing in
the picture yeah it's the same one for
the
one who was in the apocalypse in season
one the old guy yeah i remember this jfk
moment
where he does decide to give it up and
not kill the president
what is the timeline
so confusing he's so confusing because
like he's from the time bureau to kill
the president but then we're dealing
with the time bureau and like the fact
that there's like an overthrowing and
like
does it just automatically by talking to
him kind of change the timeline
right wouldn't that in and of itself
change everything that led to this very
conversation
like how is time affected exactly
because five was saying that if
if his old version of himself does not
go back and become a younger self
that five of him today does not exist
young five
right so wouldn't automatically kind of
poop in the air the fact that he sees
him
yeah so wouldn't him just going back fix
it like why do they need the briefcase
to get out
if five can go back with the right
coordinates
or i think he was [ __ ] bullshitting
is he lying yeah he totally is
okay a lot to keep up with
they didn't tell me the plan beforehand
i don't know what he's lying about
but wouldn't old five be smart enough to
figure that out then that young five is
lying to him i mean
they're all paranoid to get already to
begin with making me paranoid
who are you that was oh it's so fun
great debates
and um yeah it's brilliant teamwork too
even with like diego meeting the handler
herb
herb herb yeah that's the one okay
that's the one thing i was kind of
bothered by i say
i would say is the fact that lila would
bring him to the bureau knowing that
their whole job at the bureau is to
protect the timeline and he wanted to do
the one
thing before he even knew about the
apocalypse that would disrupt the
timeline
yeah i was like that's his whole thing
so it was kind of weird but i was like
as long as you if you can go with it
it makes for the rest of the outcome to
be really fun and interesting
her vagina needs glasses our mom did say
yeah
okay with herb i thought that was a
smart maneuver because they do
set up in the second episode how you
know like how disrespectful handler is
and like her would be smart enough to be
like there's something up with the
handler
yeah even when five shows up the guy
with the fish
the gold oh and that guy that guy's
still alive yeah she's keeping him as
like a memento to taunt
even when five encounters him his first
words are like she
brought you here or she did this didn't
she like it's reasonable to suspect
the handler right away right they set up
that mistrust
of her in him very early very early on
and with herb helping out him being like
a fan of them
i love their dynamic i love their
relationship i love
how diego actually likes it
it's awesome i love how characters can
just accept information in the show like
okay yeah there's a time where like move
on really quickly
like like raymond accepted the whole
apocalypse thing i mean he
i mean they've all been time traveling
and [ __ ] and they now live in the 60s so
like for them to adjust to like oh wow
there's a time bureau it's
i think that's pretty cool yeah the
allison and raymond stuff
i'm really touched by it i do feel like
there's a missing
beat here though because i noticed it
wasn't in the last episode
and it wasn't in this episode but two
episodes ago when it ended with them
it seemed like he really didn't know if
he could trust her or not yeah
and they kind of rushed over that and i
thought he'd be more
on edge or upset with the whole two
white boys came in here one of them
is dead now they came after you clearly
now you got all this other stuff going
on what the president's gonna die like
all these other things it's a lot to
process in such a short amount of time
but he seems like he hasn't been
anywhere near as
hostile towards her not that i really
want that for their relationship because
i'm i'm very endeared
i can't help but notice it seems like
there's a missing beat of
why is he so understanding and
sympathetic towards her now when just a
couple episodes ago it ended in a way
where he seemed like
i don't know if i could trust her yeah
yeah it's like they want to have their
human moments but like we got a story to
tell we got tonight brushed this along
visually i thought this was great was
mind-blowing as i am by this
it's pretty simple episode too like it's
it's not simple it's very complex but in
terms of like where we focus on we're
not cutting around to a bunch of stuff
it's like a few key sequences bonya
having to remember while being tortured
and i think the reasoning for
suspecting kgb and all that that's also
brilliantly told like oh yeah
vanya russian name and she doesn't
remember who she is she got back
it could be the russians we're always on
edge of the russian yeah
you could tell that the story is really
thought out in the sense of they knew
the reasoning for the apocalypse crisp
cut
clear and then decided to tell this
story this way as opposed to oh we got
this great setup now we gotta figure out
how we got here
and now knowing that's the catalyst for
the apocalypse it makes sense
the siblings without five there would
unite because they see that
that vania is still there yeah so like
oh it's so
smart this is so clever why didn't hazel
say this
[Laughter]
where does hazel play into this oh yeah
he has to come back in
he has to come back in but yeah because
i'm wondering like why didn't hazel
mention
maybe this is just the current iteration
of the timeline because there might be
something we're missing
because hazel gave five the photo of
hargraves at the jfk assassination
yes and was the the hard graves
interaction video
that was this episode right oh hard
hairs and grace too yeah
them having mistrust with each other and
you're seeing this real
emotional side to him oh my question was
it's like
yeah it was is maybe this is the younger
version of
hargraves of hargreaves and they had a
falling out or something and then
him and grace and then he decided to
make a robot
oh cause the woman he loves left him
that's what i'm trying and this is why
she left him because
diego
[Laughter]
maybe i don't know maybe they're the
reason he went to go adopt him with the
first time
predicting the times the timelines
when you binge stuff you don't have time
to stop and try to predict
how to take this one episode at a time
we're like
where's this guy oh man such a great
mind [ __ ] yeah
it's a trip a time trip oh yeah
i love those stuff for five luther is
great everyone's just killing it
everyone's killing it
this is brilliant i don't know if
there's anything we missed i think we
got it
i think we did it we just got to keep
going chugga chugga chug live on
oh yeah [ __ ] and carl carl's a dumb ass
carl
subscribe for the real rejects click the
notification bell tell us what you
thought of this episode
[Music]
you